the next Call of Duty may be a black ops
installment The Last of Us part 2 gets a
new gameplay trailer and the PlayStation
5 is apparently a lot more immersive
than we thought I'm Kurt you've made it
to save state for May 20th what's the
date today
looks like the next Call of Duty is
gonna be a black ops installment and
it's going back to where it all began
the Cold War according to Europe gamers
own sources the game will officially be
titled cue the drumroll
call of duty black ops cold war and it
was mocked up with this image by okami
13 underscore it's also suspected that
Activision is going to reveal the next
Cod in the battle royale game and given
that players are glitching themselves
through walls and fighting Cold War spy
plans all the boxes seem to be checked
on that's the direction we're going
so we'll see little by little we're
hearing more and more about the
PlayStation 5 which Sony says will be an
evolution in sound jazz hands in Sony's
latest corporate strategy meeting one of
the slides was all about new sound
possibilities quote by installing a
customized 3d audio processing unit in
PlayStation 5 we have made it possible
to deliver diverse and sophisticated 3d
audio experiences further detailing that
players can experience sound that moves
in from front to behind above to below
and all around them pair that up with a
haptic feedback controller and that's
sounding to be pretty damn immersive now
we just need the controller to spew out
fumes of gun smoke and agony and it'll
be over the full 40 experience how about
you do you want your games this next
generation have smell-o-vision let me
know in the comments The Last of Us part
2 is nearly here and just to hold us
over a little longer Naughty Dog has
released an inside gameplay trailer
introducing cue the drumroll a jump
button in the video the developers
explain new movement mechanics like
jumping dodging and being completely
prone and how they've built the world to
complement all these new features the
trailer slash feature at also details
how the world in this game is open to
entire scripted scenes that could be
missed by the player
world is alive and things are happening
whether you're seeing it or not which is
sweet because that gives us each our own
unique playthrough to talk about and
share also Naughty Dog says they're
gonna be releasing these videos leading
up to the release one more on May 27th
and then another on June 3rd so come
back here to GameSpot to get updates on
the cool stuff that you want to know but
III is not happening this summer but
GameSpot is doing play for all it's
gonna last for over a month and going to
be the quintessential place for you to
find all the latest gaming news
announcements interviews and live
streams we're also raising money for
healthcare workers who are risking their
lives daily for the cove in nineteen
relief efforts we're going to have
hundreds of hours of sweet content to
watch featuring familiar faces like us
the Giant Bomb crew kind of funnies Greg
Miller no clips Danny O'Dwyer and a
whole bunch more that we'll be
announcing over the coming weeks we hope
you come and celebrate with us see a
bunch of cool faces and support a damn
good cause that wraps up today's save
state for Wednesday May 20th I'm Kurt
feel free to bug me on twitter at kurt
underscore in davina and come back
tomorrow to see persia
she's a cool cat anyways wash your hands
do a high kick maybe a push-up if you
can stay healthy
yeah alright see ya
[Music]